[MUSIC PLAYING]
JESSICA HARROP: Hi, I'm
Jessica and today I'm
going to shed some light on
a chemical demonstration I
like to call anatomy
of a glow stick.
There are many different
kinds of chemical reactions.
Some absorb energy and
some release energy.
Some release energy as
heat and others as light.
And when a reaction
produces light,
the process is called
chemiluminescence.
Let's watch MIT's Dr. John
Dolhun, his assistant,
Shannon, and volunteers,
Sarah, Catherine, and Trevor.
They are going to show
us some chemiluminescence
at the Cambridge
Science Festival.
[WHOOSH]
SHANNON MOREY: So not all
reactions have this ability
to produce light.
And so we have to use some
very special chemicals in order
to do this.
And we have some light sticks
that I broke apart here,
if you guys just want
to take these solutions.
Hold them carefully.
And so in a light
stick, usually there's
actually hydrogen peroxide.
And it oxidizes different
chemicals-- oh, yeah,
you can just face the audience.
That's cool.
And it will oxidize
different chemicals
depending on what color
you want to give off light.
All right.
So just pour one
solution together.
It doesn't matter which way.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
SHANNON MOREY: And
there we go, OK.
Beautiful, beautiful.
All right.
So in each of these, we
have a different chemical
that gets oxidized to
give us a different color.
All right, thank
you guys so much.
[APPLAUSE]
[WHOOSH]
JESSICA: So how does a
reaction produce light?
Let's start with two molecules.
Let's call them A
and B. They react
to produce C and D. Energy
that's produced in the reaction
causes the electrons
in D to become excited.
As the electrons
relax back down,
they give off energy as light.
So basically, chemical energy is
transformed into light energy.
This all happens in one step
as the reaction is progressing.
Here's what's happening.
This is the energy level of
our reactants, A and B. When
they react, they form C
and D in its excited state.
Now to relax back down
to where it needs to be,
D emits energy as light.
Now there's a different
amount of energy
in our reactants
than our products,
so that's why these two
energy levels are different.
All right, so in Dr.
Dolhun's experiment,
each volunteer has a cup
containing a different chemical
and adds hydrogen
peroxide to each cup.
And each cup glows a different
color, red, blue, or green.
This happens because
the hydrogen peroxide
is oxidizing each of
the different chemicals.
So oxidation is the chemical
reaction that will ultimately
cause the chemiluminescence.
So why did each
of these chemicals
glow a different color?
Well it's because
they each emitted
a different amount of energy.
And energy equals color.
So let's think of it in
terms of a rainbow spectrum.
So the amount of
energy increases
as you move up the spectrum.
So red is lower
energy than blue.
So if the difference between
the ground state and the excited
state is small, there
is a smaller amount
of energy released,
and the light
is on the redder
side of the spectrum.
Conversely, if
that gap is larger,
there's more energy released.
So the light is on the
bluer side of the spectrum.
And this chemiluminescence
chemistry
has practical uses
beyond glowsticks
that light up a good party.
We also use reactions
like these to create
flares that don't get too hot
in use of emergency situations.
And nature uses
chemiluminescence too.
[WHOOSH] If you've ever
seen a firefly light up
at night or an [WHOOSH] Angler
fish hunt for prey, you've seen
bioluminescence which
is chemiluminescence
in a biological system.
It's the exact same principle
as the chemical reactions
that Dr. Dolhun showed us.
[MUSIC PLAYING] Hope
you enjoyed the video.
I'll see you next time.